The thing I would say is some of you guys ask, like, when do you ask these questions?
When do you ask about their profit, their ticket size, their close percentage?
You can ask it whenever the hell you want, but here's what I found is if I go through the steps
of the prospecting script, as long as you get your main pitch out and they're still listening to you,
you let them know, hey, I'm going to send you some leads. I want to talk in a couple days.
And they're still cool with that. You got airtime and you just have to read it as a human. Like
after that, and they're like, yeah, that sounds good. Okay, cool. I'm going to send you a lead,
blah, blah, blah. Who do I send it to? Now? I got a little bit of time. If they're giving it to me,
I'm going to ask them to say, okay, so just to double check, do you guys, you guys will
do concrete repairs or do you strictly want like new work? And they're like, okay, new work. All
right. And do you do stamp and flat work or just like, that's a perfect time with what Josh is
saying. Make sure, okay, is there any zip codes that you don't cover? Because obviously every city
has some ghetto and I, you know, I can't get, there's going to be some stuff that comes in
just naturally, but it would be nice to know upfront if you just won't go there, whatever, right?